news daily from science mission  mechanism of maintaining pluripotent  state of mouse embryonic stem cells  without differentiation is not  understood authors in the journal Nature  communications show that mitochondrial  III like is March file is a  transcriptional target of klf4 much I  catalyzes poly ubiquitination of protein  kr1 a a regulator is a minute of PKA to  activate PKA thereby inhibiting here k  pathway and maintains pluripotency next  prostaglandin e to differentiate t  helper 17 lymphocyte that is t at 17 and  activated th17 has been implicated in  autoimmune diseases although the  mechanism is not known scientists show  that prostaglandin e2 enhances th17 cell  differentiation via activation of creb  co-activator crtc to following its  dephosphorylation crtc to binds to crab  and stimulates expression of the  cytokines there by differentiating th17  for more details visit as a www in calm  or science mission facebook page thanks  for watching